elle fêtera ses 100 ans en 2020 si la
maison feuillette a encore fière allure
ce n'est pas le cas de tous les
bâtiments du site il ya beaucoup de
travail à faire l'an garde de 1920 il a
été fait par le l'ingénieur feuillette
en même temps que la maison je crois
même tout petit peu avant la
restauration de ce hangar mais aussi la
construction d'un nouveau bâtiment de
150 m² sur la parcelle voisine
tous ces plans font partie du projet
européen obs trop lancé en 2017 avec
pour chef de file le centre national de
la construction paille le centre a pour
but bien sûr de développer le matériau
paille en tant que matériaux de
construction en france et grâce au
projet européen on peut émuler cette
envie mais cette fois ci sur l'europe du
nord ouest puisque c'est c'est la zone
qui nous concerne un projet à 500000
euros pour la partie française financée
par la région centre à hauteur de 40 %
le reste étant à charge de l'europe
problème
l'association doit avancer les frais et
il manque 130000 euros pour convaincre
la banque
la région nous a aidés à hauteur de 75
mille euros et là ça ne permettra pas de
garder tous les tous les salariés et il
nous aurait fallu 130 milles afin de
garder les deux salaires et demi puisque
il ya une personne à mi-temps et
et là nous allons être obligés de
licencier c'est donc un effort
supplémentaire de la région pour mener à
bien le projet mais il était difficile
d'aller au delà des 75000 euros
bien sûr il aurait fallu mettre beaucoup
plus mais le risque pour nous était
grand de voir ce projet fragilisé et
parce qu'en fait il aurait dépendu 100 %
des financements de la région et puis l
incertitude sur les fonds européens
ce type de projet doit trouver aussi son
propre modèle économique et ça ne peut
pas être que avec de l'argent public
le programme ppte euro permettrait à
l'association de développer sa formation
mais elle nourrit maintenant l'espoir de
survivre au financement du projet